hi in this video we'll talk about how
dengue test works if you are from a
tropical climate you know dengue is a
big problem especially if you're from
south america africa or india you know
every year a lot of people get affected
by dengue and it's a nasty fever
so sometimes you might experience that
fever with chill
and this might be due to dengue
so if you are having a fever and chill
you should get yourself tested for
dengue
but we need to know how this test work
how to interpret the result and what
precautions you can take
so let's start from the beginning
dengue is caused by a virus which is
from a flavivirid family and this virus
is mosquito bone that means
it is transmitted via mosquito
and it's important to get tested for
dengue if you have high fever associated
with chills especially if you are in
this tropical climate region
now ns1 antigen test is done for
detecting
a dengue virus and the method which is
used is elisa
ns1 antigen test is very simple it is
based on the principle that we need to
detect a fragment or a small portion of
the virus to understand whether the
virus is present in our body or not ns1
antigen is a non-structural protein and
this protein should be present in
infected patients blood so by detecting
ns1 antigen we can understand the status
of dengue virus infection
so this is the
dengue genome and one small portion of
the genome encodes for the ns1 protein
and in this elisa assay we detect the
ns1 antigen itself
in order to perform this test blood
samples are collected from the patients
and the serum is extracted in the
pathological laboratory and in the lab
let us tell you what kind of test is
performed
so in the microtiter plate elisa would
be performed
all the wells of the microtiter plate
would be covered
with specific antibodies which are known
to detect
ns1 antigen
then
patient sample would be provided in
these microtiter plate we have
expectation that patient sample might
contain
the ns1 antigen
so let us add the
patient plasma sample
if patient sample has ns1 antigen then
it would bind to the antibody
so
after washing it we provide a secondary
antibody which is enzyme linked
now we provide substrate
now once we provide substrate it would
eventually show some color and this
color reaction is indicative of a
positive test if color is developed the
test is positive obviously we don't
determine the color or the intensity of
this color by a naked eyes
we do it in a sophisticated elisa
machine
which measure the absorbance
with a sophisticated software
now this is the report
here our reference range would be
provided for you negative test is
indicated by a value which is lower than
9 a positive test means a value which is
greater than 11
and these are all antigen units
so let's say in this particular report
you can see the value to be 2.31
so obviously the test is negative let's
say the value is 13.5
then the test is positive
now let us try to understand we need to
get tested within the seven days of
fever onset
now whenever we
get infected with dengue our body also
responds by making antibodies specific
to dengue virus
there are other ways to get tested for
dengue
to understand
how much of antibody has been produced
in the body
okay so here
our body produces plasma cells
which produce igm or igg specific for
dengue virus and these antibodies would
neutralize the virus so if we are able
to detect these
dengue specific antibodies in the
patient serum
then it is likely that that particular
patient was infected by dengue so it's
kind of a indirect readout
now let us try to understand the immune
kinetics behind that so let's say we
have a first infection
within a seven to ten days span there
would be an elevation of igm level
so we can detect that igm level via
elisa
now after 20 to 30 days there would be
elevation of igg antibody levels
and all these antibody levels can be
determined by
elisa assay so again patient sample is
collected and from the serum elisa is
performed
now there are other kind of tests which
can be done for dengue viruses such as
tnv one to four real-time quantitative
pcr assay
now this particular assay determines the
virus specific rna in a patient's blood
sample
and this particular assay can also tell
us about the viruses serotype that means
what type of virus has
actually infected you
these kind of tests are generally used
by scientists to determine in a
particular season in a particular area
which type of dengue virals virus
serotype is dominant but this is not a
prescribed test for individuals so i
hope this particular video was helpful
and now you know what is the biology
behind ns1 antigen test and how to
understand the result behind it so if
you like this video give it a quick
thumbs up don't forget to like share and
subscribe if you wish to subscribe to my
channel you should also check out my uh
social media links all are provided in
the description thank you for listening
see you in the next video